I saw you in the offer
and it just blew me away
it blew me away I was like this because
I don't you don't get to be serious as
much as you get to be kind of funny guy
right
yeah yeah but boy I mean they gave me a
chance well they always say
uh comedy's harder right as an actor so
the comedy's harder serious is easier I
I always felt like that too do you feel
like that
yeah absolutely because yeah you don't
have to
comedy is like math you have to you have
to hit it's like music if you don't hit
the right chords if you don't hit the
right
phone they're not gonna laugh and it's
just like it doesn't work you know so
it's it's a real art but drama
you can just be yeah you know don't make
anyone laugh you just you just are
um and that could be funny too you can
find some dark hysterical moments in
there but
uh it's a lot easier yeah
um Coppola man he's he's a serious dude
and yeah Jesus so that was like and he's
he's obviously an iconic legend alive
um it was a lot it was big shoes to step
into and um
and he and he can be kind of funny you
know and in some ways so you met him no
but I feel like uh
I've seen him
you know he's eccentric uh and he's
passionate
and
you know he like
you there are moments in Apocalypse Now
that are
surrealy hysterical
um a heart and like heart to Darkness
you watch him in that but he's in
Apocalypse Now and that moment is so
surreal and hysterical where he just saw
don't look at me look keep going
yeah yeah I remember that she could just
like you know it takes it takes a a
Darkly comedic mind to no he he it
that's an opera like The Godfather is an
opera he creates like Dracula's are
these like operas and so
you have to hit every note on the piano
you have to hit every
uh color on the palette like that's what
he does so there is this there's a
little comedy and everything and the
offer I I don't tell you to watch a lot
of things this is a great series if
you've never heard of it it's sort of
like how the Godfather movie came to be
how it was made and all the difficulties
the adversity they faced which I had no
idea the [__] that this movie almost
went down went under so many times and
the stories are so fascinating that
you're like this can't be true and then
you start looking [__] up after you're
watching you're like wow this is true
this happened
yeah yeah life is even Stranger in
fiction
um
yeah and the show
had did kind of um
squeeze in a couple a couple years of
history there
um but there was there's
I'd say about you know 85 percent of
that show is are real things that
happened and real
um like every day was a battle just to
make
the movie yeah uh like like first
um like Coppola first Coppola didn't
want to make it he was just like I don't
know I don't like how it makes
Italians look and and then like the
legend is is that
uh George Lucas was just like dude
they're gonna they're gonna shut this
place down they're gonna they're gonna
lock the doors of American Zoe Trope you
gotta do this movie so it's just like he
was like okay and
and then um in meeting Mario Puzo
he just
um found this kindred spirit who was
just like
this
you know other because
um he's basically a writing genius
copelism it was a writing genius in his
own right he wrote Pat and won the
Academy Award for that and so he really
hit it off with with Mario and and
um and from them they really paired down
the gold from that novel
uh and those are some of my favorite
scenes oh yeah when you're with Puzo and
Puzo and just sitting there and have a
sand with a sandwich thing and the yeah
it's just it's it's hilarious and you're
like how are they gonna do this how are
we gonna get anything done
see it's funny there's there's funny
moments absolutely it's like yeah
they're uh the two of them
the two of them are a great Odd Couple
in a lot of ways yeah
kuzo is just like it's you know sloppy
and couples just like stay on stay on
target yeah